well first of all what's called
libertarian
in the united states is some ultra-right
uh advocacy of private tyrannies
nothing nothing like anything that was
libertarian traditionally
but if you're talking about left
libertarian it's
[Music]
you know covers quite a range but
just as the term anarchism does but
there is a kind of a core
at the center of it i think the core
running through the whole tradition with
many variations
is the recognition that there are
certain
structures uh in social
political life economic life that are
uh that have to justify their own
legitimacy
they are coercive uh authoritarian
there's hierarchy domination somebody
gives the order somebody takes them
uh all of those structures have to be
aren't none of those structures are
self-justified
they have a burden of justification if
they can't meet it which is almost
always the case they should be
dismantled
i think that's the core principle and my
own view
is that once you get to the basics
almost every normal person's
in this sense but that's then you have
to ask how it applies
so do you have a job somewhere well if
you have a job
in a business corporation let's say
you're living in a tyranny so extreme
that no totalitarian dictator ever
dreamed of it
so for example stalin didn't tell people
that you have 10 minutes to go to the
bathroom every couple hours
you have to wear these clothes not some
other clues you're not let's stop to
talk to a friend for a minute uh your
monitor
say at an amazon warehouse so that if
you don't pick up enough things fast
enough
like you maybe you stop to breathe or
something
you get a demerit there's no
totalitarian dictatorship like that
that's most of people's lives well is
that a legitimate
uh structure is the labor contract
legitimate actually traditional
classical liberals didn't think so
uh abraham lincoln didn't think so the
republican party didn't think so
the republican party's slogan in the
mid-19th century early industrial
revolution was that
uh wage labor is indistinguishable from
slavery
except that it's supposed to be
temporary until you become a free person
again
well okay that's uh that those ideas
have been driven out of people's heads
but i don't think they're very far below
the surface
they can emerge and that would be
authentic uh less libertarian just
one aspect